they are not foolish enough to see that
the pikes would eventually take over the
whole planet apparently i missed this
confusing statement in the last episode
thanks for the assist previously on the
more appropriate phrase is they are not
foolish enough to not see that the pikes
will eventually take over the whole
planet so now that's two sins because
it's wrong in two episodes book of mando
you look lost and it looks like you have
your office in a [ __ ] meat locker we
can't all be perfect i can bring you in
warm
or i can bring you in cold this version
of the i can bring you in dead or alive
cliche lacks clarity and could be
misinterpreted as i can bring you in
with or without hot cocoa also biting
someone in a fight is a sin for sure but
is he biting mando's thumb or the gun
because it looks like he's biting the
[ __ ] gun who would even do that even
mike tyson wouldn't do well okay i guess
maybe mike tyson would do that but
surely no one else would i want to
remove one sin for the sheer joy i
experienced at the deployment of this
nightsaber but i also have to add us in
because lucasfilm knows what i want is
giving it to me and i feel dirty
also a non-jedi with no training brings
a saber to a gunfight and it [ __ ]
works despite witnessing the failure of
his co-workers as they just attempted
the same thing caba baez shoots the
heavily armored individual in the armor
to no effect mando is a dick to tables
show deprives me of seeing this
structure in its entirety i've got so
many questions like why does the ring
have a gap is it still under
construction is this part of the space
zoned for multi-family residential
staring at someone on an elevator
elevator rides with other people are
awkward enough don't make it weirder
learn the etiquette part of me is loving
this entire sequence but the other part
of me feels like i ordered a book of
boba fett sandwich so far all i'm
getting is a slathering of the
mandalorian a few slices of halo and now
a sprinkling of mass effect just saying
where's the bob
[Music]
only one platter and two sides of these
orange balls no one wants to touch this
hardly looks like a feast and it also
looks like everyone's finished eating
already so this is really just an
invitation to attempt a conversation
while being the only person at the table
eating we all know this just ends with
people watching you chew and you feeling
weird about it
being willing to sit calmly in feast
when someone sets a decapitated head on
the table i don't care if that shit's in
a bag it still smells like a decapitated
head it's really unfortunate this leg
injury didn't happen earlier in the year
mandalorian insurance isn't great but
it's better than nothing however when
you get in that donut hole it's very
hard to get out am i right based on the
average age of our viewers i'm guessing
most of you will understand this joke in
about 40 years all this talk of the
empire and they lasted less than 30
years
mandalorians have existed 10 000. in the
first 12 minutes of this episode it felt
like at least 15 years so your point is
what exactly also history lessons i am
told it is the dark saber this blade's
position goes on for some time just to
give us a bunch of metrics by which
we're supposed to determine whether
mando is or is not the one whoever
wields it
can lead all of mandalore if it is won
by creed in battle i mean i haven't seen
michael b jordan in this episode but i
guess he could be showing up later seems
more likely at this point than boba fett
showing up mandalore will be laid to
waste and its people scattered to the
four winds later the show goes on to
describe events that make it sound like
mandalore has already been laid to waste
so it kind of seems like it doesn't
matter who has this thing anymore
death would have been justice for his
atrocities
this is true the armorer is that friend
that shows up after you've moved all the
heavy pieces of furniture so you're
hanging out with all these tools in the
previous scene put them back in are now
whipping them out again and the forge
wasn't even operational it can also
pierce beskarama
its mere existence puts mandalorians at
risk these mandalorians really like
talking shop about singular weapons
maybe if they thought big picture they'd
still have a planet those born of
mandalore strayed away from the path
this footage makes it look less like
they strayed from the path and more like
the path was obliterated by suborbital
bombardment discount war of the machines
only those that walked the way escaped
the curse prophesied in the creed
seriously did disney buy the rocky
franchise or something cause if you're
telling me the rocky movies are now
connected with star wars i have become
at least two percent more interested in
this episode i've also become seven
percent less interested math was never
my strong suit also this prophecy talk
prophesizes for all the some time what
shall i forge for the foundling
grogu a better name she hammers the end
of the spear a few times and then
quenches it and voila we have tiny metal
rings whoever thought that we wouldn't
be more interested in this entire
process has completely overlooked the
success of forged in fire also the
suggestion here is that this will be
some sort of chain mail but we aren't
even allowed to see the finished product
yet and i don't like being frock teased
i am focused
the blade says otherwise blades can't
talk it was forged by my ancestor
founder of house vizla then why didn't
you bring this up earlier this future
fight feels forced and filler-esque in
fact let's just give it 25 cents here
because while i'm always happy to see
mando this entire episode seems like a
desperate attempt to force fetus a new
mandalorian episode so people would keep
watching boba fett minus the boba and
the fat
dinjarin have you ever removed your
helmet the mandalorians sure do like
rules i guess i get that it's just that
this helmet check really derails the
momentum of this scene it's like someone
whipped out a challenge coin i'm sorry
flight with your sir
no one will be seated while mando goes
through a tsa checkpoint
kids when you miss someone you see them
everywhere you look cliche wally's
cousin pops up on screen don't get me
wrong i always love meeting a new member
of the family but disney you're getting
very close to creating a cute and
lovable droid cliche also creating a
cute and lovable droid to tear my heart
out when it gets eaten by a predatory
animal also also why is a predatory
animal trying to eat a robot there's
gotta be so little nutritional value in
those things what is she even shooting
at the creature's gone behind the engine
block she's just wasting ammo and pelly
doesn't strike me as someone who would
be wasting ammo you can't say no you're
a droid indentured servotude show goes
down the route of making spaceships seem
to have the same complexity as muscle
cars suggesting that anyone with enough
gumption can repair or rebuild one don't
worry about the shape and size just get
the parts you want the specs you need
and i'm gonna make it work all right i
dated a jawa i don't see how your dating
record makes you more or less qualified
to modify spaceship parts detail that
seems lost on the mandalorian a literal
and metaphorical indication of disney's
desire to shove weird creatures into
every orifice of this franchise
sparks equal fixing you hit this button
you're going to evacuate your exhaust
manifold if you know what i mean title
of my sex tape ever since i've been
moving spice to the system everything's
gone to hell i'm not concerned with the
obvious comparisons to dune the problem
here is that my imagination immediately
puts the two franchises in the same
universe and i can't decide now if i do
or don't want that to happen the panel
that had mando all confused before is no
longer on the ship that's a lot of
engine for a little ship it's also the
wrong engine noise for a spaceship i
think they put a little too much
internal combustion in their j-type
pulse engines these flight maneuvers
around this ship look really awesome and
do give the space police a reason to
pull him over but this seems reckless
and oddly out of character fermando are
we reporting this
you want to go back to base fill out
reports all day even in a galaxy far far
away excessive paperwork is the hurdle
between doing and not doing your job
those j-type pulse engines really
tighten the old evacuation port don't
they cho takes a second shot at this
excretion joke and now i'm left
wondering if there is a meaningful
difference between the exhaust manifold
and the evacuation port tell them it's
on the house but first
i gotta pay a visit to a little friend i
usually don't care for these spin-off
episodes but i really enjoyed this
character i hope he gets his own show i
gotta know who that little guy is
i was going into toshi station to pick
up some power converters
well looks like you finally got your
crossover episode
and in my club i will splash the pot
whenever the
i please
[Music]
[Music]
what do you know of this
blade this
toasts
bread
while you're slicing it
the blade says otherwise
for this test sir
it will not kill
i have
then you are a mandalorian no more
yeah i got the memo and i understand the
policy and the problem is just that i
forgot the one time and i've already
taken care of it so it's not even really
a problem anymore
what a piece of sh
ever since they've been moving spice to
the system everything's gone to hell
human sacrifice dogs and cats living
together mass hysteria
[Music]
man this baby must corner like it's on
rails
tell him it's on the house
but first
i gotta pay a visit to a little friend
shout out to my new friend